right in my hands brand-new with this
our bombshell revelations from the
Grassley gram memo major parts this is
the memo from yesterday have now been
unredacted huge part yesterday
now the memo was providing further
evidence that the FISA Court was lied to
by the FBI in order to get a warrant to
spy on the Trump campaign and there's
new information that Christopher Steele
may have lied to the FBI about briefing
media outlets there's a lot to cover
we're going to go through it slowly
we'll do it together
now the memo starts with this this is
page one of the memo right here on the
face the dossier it appears that mr.
Steele gathered much of his information
from Russian government sources inside
of Russia and according to the law firm
Perkins Coie mr. Steele's dossier
related efforts were funded through
fusion GPS by that law firm on behalf of
the Democratic National Committee and
the Clinton campaign let's pause here
Hillary Clinton is paying Steele to
spread Russian lies and Russian
propaganda I'll read it again because
this is important much of the
information from Russian government
sources inside of Russia isn't that what
the media's been investigating for the
better part of a year here
oh so keep that in mind as we move
forward
here's another key portion it appears
that either mr. Steele lie to the FBI or
to the British Court that the classified
documents were viewed by the committee
contain materially false statements and
then the memo goes on to read in
response to the committee's inquiries
the Chairman and ranking member received
a briefing March 15 2017 from then
director James Comey then the memo goes
on to say that briefing addressed the
Russia investigation the FBI's
relationship with mr. steel and the
FBI's reliance on mr. Steele's dossier
in to applications that it filed for
surveillance under the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act then March
17th 2017 the Chairman and ranking
member will provided copies of the two
relevant FISA applications which
requested authority to
conduct surveillance of quarter-page
both relied heavily on mr. Steele's
dossier claims and both applications
were granted by the Foreign Intelligence
Court in December 2017 the chairman
ranking member and subcommittee chairman
Graham were allowed to review a total of
four FISA applications relying on the
dossier to seek surveillance of mr.
Carter page as well as numerous other
FBI documents related to mr. Steele
now the next paragraph this is
interesting this is highly redacted here
I wonder what's in that then the
following paragraph follow along
similarly in June of 2017 the former FBI
director Comey testified publicly before
the Senate Select Committee on
Intelligence that he had briefed
president-elect Trump on the dossiers
allegations in January when he was
president-elect just before he was sworn
into office January 2017 which mr. Comey
described to then president-elect Trump
as salacious and unverified when asked
at the March 2017 briefing why the FBI
then relied on the dossier in the FISA
applications absent meaningful
corroboration and in the light of the
highly political motives surrounding its
creation then director Comey stated that
the FBI included the dossier allegations
about Carter page in the FISA
applications because mr. Steele himself
was considered reliable due to his past
work with the FBI now later on that page
memo reads it goes the bulk paid close
attention the bulk of the FISA
application put that back up on the
screen consists of allegations against
page that were disclosed to the FBI by
mr. Steele and also outlined in the
steel dossier the application appears to
contain no additional information
corroborating the dossier allegations
against mr. page
although it does cite to a news article
that appears to be sourced to mr.
Steele's dossier as well let's just stop
right here the entire bulk of the FISA
application
came from the dossier this dossier well
they're relying on a guy that was being
paid for by the Clinton campaign and by
the DNC funneling the money fusion GPS
got the money through the law firm both
the DNC and the Clinton campaign used
there was no verification of any of this
it was just based on the dossier and the
fact that they say well he was reliable
in the past and then imagine this in
October when they file for the first
application for FISA against the Trump
campaign well three months later in
January James Comey is saying that it's
salacious and unverified so why three
months earlier did they go before a FISA
Court and presented as the bulk of
evidence do you see where we're going
here now here's what page three of this
memo says redacted the FBI discussed the
reliability of the unverified
information provided by mr. Steele in
footnotes 8 and 18 of the FISA warrant
application first
the FBI noted a vaguely limited extent
the political origins of the dossier
stop right there
they knew it was funded by Hillary
Clinton and the DNC they never told the
FISA Court that important piece of
information I think the FISA Court
probably would have made a big
impression considering this is the bulk
of their case the dossier if it was
coming from one campaign against another
campaign in the lead-up to an election
now in footnote 8 the FBI stated the
dossier information was compiled
pursuant to the direction of a law firm
who had hired an identified US person
now known as Glenn Simpson Fuzion GPS
then redacted the application failed to
disclose that the identities of mr.
Simpson's ultimate clients or the
Clinton campaign and the DNC why would
the FBI FBI in making a FISA application
against an opposition party in an
election year and knowing it's paid for
by the Clinton campaign in the DNC why
would they not tell the FISA Court
that to me is a serious omission and one
that states there's a political motive
behind all of this now let's just go
back a little further remember this is
the same James Comey this is the same
FBI that in fact in spite of a mountain
of evidence that Hillary Clinton
mishandled classified information
destroyed and deleted 33,000 subpoenaed
emails and then used acid wash and then
bleach pit and then busted up you know
different devices with hammers the same
people that kept her in the race are now
working on her behalf again and they're
doing it in this case by not telling the
full truth to the FISA Court we continue
the FBI stated to the FISA Court that
based on Steele's previous reporting and
history with the FBI whereby steel
provided reliable information to the FBI
the FBI believes Steele's reporting to
be credible in short it appears the FBI
relied on admittedly uncorroborated
information funded by and obtained for
secretary Clinton's presidential
campaign in order to conduct
surveillance of an associate of an
opposing presidential candidate it did
these are this is right here in this
right here it did so based on mr.
Steele's personal credibility and
presumably having faith in his process
of obtaining information Wow
they didn't tell the court any of this
they didn't tell the court where the
money came from they didn't tell the
court they also knew at that time that
Steele hated Trump because Trump because
Steele mentioned it to Bruce or we'll
get to that in a minute
but there is substantial evidence
suggesting that mr. Steele materially
misled the FBI about a key aspect of his
dossier efforts one which bears on his
credibility and it starts redacted yet
the FISA applications note the existence
of a news article dated September 23rd
2016 which in particular contained some
of the same dossier information about
mr. page compiled by mr. Steele on which
the FBI relied in its application will
not explicitly stated this is presumably
the article written by Michael is a
coffee ahoo news titled US Intel
officials probe ties between Trump
advisor and Kremlin now redacted the
application attempts to explain away the
inconsistency between Steele's assertion
to the FBI and the existence of the
article apparently to shield mr.
Steele's credibility on which it still
relied for the renewal requests of the
FISA application you got to renew it
every 90 days and it said given that the
information contained in the September
23rd news article generally matches the
information about page that Steele
discovered doing his/her research
redacted now stop for a second so they
used the same information from the same
person they presented to the court like
they're two separate but yet
corroborating pieces of information to
put emphasis to the court oh see we've
got two sources the only problem is the
source of the Yahoo News article was the
same source of the dossier is the same
guy that didn't want Trump to win and is
the same guy that was being paid by the
Clinton campaign this is so corrupt and
here's what's on page four got it right
here all of this right here in footnote
9 of its January 2017 application this
is the first renewal of the FISA warrant
in this case for mr. page the FBI again
addressed mr. Steele's credibility this
is three months later remember that's
the same January where James Comey told
President Trump its salacious and it's
unverified so that same month they go in
for a renewal back to the document the
FBI noted that it had suspended their
relationship with mr. Steele in October
2016 because of Steele's quote
unauthorized disclosure of information
of the Pres now the FBI relayed that
Steele had been bothered by the FBI's
notification to Congress in October 2016
about the reopening of the Clinton
investigation remember that happened
just before the election and as a result
Steele independently and against prior
admonishment from the FBI
to speak with only the FBI on this
matter released the reporting discussed
here in dossier allegations against
Paige
to an identified news organization
however the FBI continue to still cite
mr. Steele's past work as evidence three
months later of his reliability at the
same time they're tellin Donald Trump
it's unverified and salacious and that
incident that led to the FBI suspending
their relationship with mr. Steele
occurred after Steele provided the FBI
with the dossier information described
in the application
now the FBI further asserted in footnote
19 that it did not believe that Steele
directly gave information to Yahoo News
that published the September 23rd news
article now in the next paragraph this
is what it reads in defending mr.
Steele's credibility to the FISA Court
the FBI had posted an innocuous
explanation for the September 23rd
article based on the assumption that mr.
Steele had told the FBI the truth about
his press contacts and the FBI then
vouch for him twice more using the same
rationale in subsequent renewal
applications
you know filed with the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court in April
and in June of 2017 now here's the
important part of page five the first of
these filings was publicly reported in
the US media in April of 2017 yet
the FBI did not subsequently disclose to
the FISA Court the evidence suggesting
that Steele had lied to the FBI instead
the application still relied primarily
remember the bulk of the the application
is the phony Clinton bought and paid for
dossier go back to scroll down just a
hair back the other way the bulk of the
application so instead the application
is still we're now six months into this
thing relied on his credibility even
though the FBI knew he was not credible
at this point especially as it relates
to the media incident which pushed him
out of the FBI's way in October the same
month the first FISA warrant was granted
now here's what's on page six whether
mr. Steele lied to the FBI about his
media contacts
is relevant for at least two reasons
first it's relevant to his credibility
as a source particularly given the lack
of corroboration for his claims at least
at the time they were included in the
FISA applications second it is relevant
to the reliability of his information
gathering efforts mr. Steele conducted
his work for fusion gps compiling the
pre-election memoranda between June and
early November 2016 now there was this
British litigation this talks about it
in the Grassley and gram memo here
tonight mr. Steele acknowledged briefing
journalists about the dossier memorandum
in late summer autumn 2016 yeah he was
the source for Issachar
now unsurprisingly during the summer of
2016
reports of at least some of the dossier
allegations began to circle circulating
among reporters and people involved in
Russia issues mr. Steele also admitted
in the British litigation to briefing
journalists from The Washington Post
Yahoo News The New Yorker the whole
network fake News CNN in September 2016
simply put the more people who
contemporaneously knew that mr. Steele
was compiling his dossier the more
likely it was vulnerable to manipulation
in fact in the British litigation which
involves a post-election dossier
memorandum Steele admitted he had
received and included it in unsolicited
unverified allegations that filing
implies that he similarly received
unsolicited intelligence on these
matters prior to the election as well
stating that mr. Steele continued to
receive unsolicited intelligence now pay
close attention on matters covered by
the pre-election memorandum after the
u.s. presidential election
now the next paragraphs redacted it goes
on one memorandum by mr. Steele that was
not published by BuzzFeed is dated
October 19 2016 the report alleges
redacted as well redacted mr. Steele's
memorandum states that his company
received this report redacted US State
Department that the report was the
second in a series and that the report
pay close attention was information that
came from
foreign subsys who is in touch with
redacted a contact of redacted a friend
of the clintons
who passed it to redacted I love the
redacted here it is troubling enough the
Clinton campaign funded Steele's work
but that now clinton associates as we
reported last night
well contemporaneously feeding mr. steel
allegations this raises additional
concern about his credibility let's head
to page seven these facts appear to
directly contradict the FBI's assertions
in its initial application in October of
2016 for the FISA warrant as well as
subsequent renewal applications the FBI
repeatedly represented to the FISA Court
that mr. Steele told the FBI he did not
have unauthorized contacts with the
press about the dossier prior to October
2016 that's false
the FISA applications make these claims
specifically in the context of the
September 2016 Yahoo News article but
mr. steel has admitted publicly before a
court of law that he did have such
contacts with the press at this time and
his former business partner mr. Simpson
had confirmed it to the committee thus
the FISA applications are either
materially false in claiming that mr.
Steele said he did not provide dossier
information of the press prior to
October 2016 or mr. Steele made
materially false statements to the FBI
when he claimed he only provided the
dossier information to his business
partner in the FBI and page seven
continues in this case Steele's apparent
deception seems to have posed
significant material consequences on the
FBI's investigative decision and
representations to the FISA Court and
steals information formed a significant
portion of the FBI warrant application
FISA application relied more heavily on
Steele's credibility than on any
independent verification or
corroboration for his claims thus the
basis for the warrant authorising
surveillance on a u.s. citizen
largely rests on mr. Steele's
credibility
and the Department of Justice has a
responsibility to determine whether mr.
Steele provided false information to the
FBI and whether the FBI's
representations to the court were in
error